how did the villain in wakanda Forever
steal the show and what was the biggest
complaint about the movie keep watching
for what critics are saying about the
latest installment in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
going into this film many MCU fans were
wondering how it would handle the death
of Chadwick Boseman we can't give
anything away but Twitter reactions are
proving Ryan coogler honored his friend
properly one critic tweeted black
panther wakanda forever is the best film
of mcu's phase 4. with the strongest
emotional core of the entire franchise
it overcomes its unfocused structure and
overbearing length to stand tall as a
powerful reflection that perfectly
honors Chadwick boseman's Legacy another
agreed adding emotionally rich and
technically brilliant Ryan coogler's
directing hand is felt throughout
tenochuerta is an absolute standout as
Namor Chadwick boseman's Legacy is
honored well a major theme being
discussed on Twitter is the World
building coogler managed to cram in the
film's 2 hour and 41 minute run time
wakanda forever introduces the
underwater nation of talocon where
Neymar Reigns it certainly is not easy
to introduce a whole new world in in the
MCU especially within a movie focused on
wakanda and its people one critic wrote
that wakanda forever is a quote solid
mix of developing a post-chadwick path
Plus World building for future MCU
stories wakanda forever is certainly an
emotional outing but Twitter reviews
suggest it's so much more than a legacy
film it's also a throwback to the great
films of the infinity Saga including the
original black panther finding a wakanda
forever tweet that doesn't praise Angela
Bassett is like finding a needle in a
haystack the Academy Award nominee who
played Queen ramonda might get another
nod thrown her way at the next Oscars if
Twitter has anything to say about it one
critic tweeted the best Marvel Studios
anything in at least five years so much
imagination and energy and emotion never
bogged down by the larger MCU framework
tenoch Huerta is a damn star and Angela
Bassett is a legend have I not given
everything another shining star in
wakanda forever is tinochuerta who is
getting ample amounts of Praise on
social media a Critic wrote to nochuerta
steals every moment another added to
nochuerta and Leticia Wright give strong
performances with the former stealing
the movie Wright also gets lots of
compliments on Twitter with a film
YouTuber writing she is at some of her
best here with shuri her story in the
film is a powerful one and Wright
deserves all the credit for what she
brought to the table if the tweets
surrounding wakanda forever are any
indication this might just be the best
film in Phase 4 of the MCU it will
likely battle Spider-Man no way home in
debates about the best but if you're
looking for a solid well-rounded film
that doesn't rely on Fanfare and cameos
the Black Panther sequel looks to take
the cake
perhaps one of the biggest talking
points amongst moviegoers is Namor as
the mcu's newest villain is a scene
stealer after seeing the flick Thursday
a viewer wrote got a new favorite MCU
character in Namor loved how to know
chuerta brought him to life and loved
the world of talocon fantastic idea to
infuse Mesoamerican culture into it I
wish we got to spend more time down
there but what we see is beautifully
realized
[Music]
someone else agreed writing talocon was
beautiful I hope we get to see more of
namor's Kingdom I love World building it
was so cool but my enemies call me no
more the MCU has always had something of
a villain problem sure there are some
greats but a majority of the marble
antagonists have been either relatively
dull or total Duds that lack the
complexity of the movie's good guys it
looks like Namor is helping to balance
it all out as the character is being
hailed as one of the film's highlights
another viewer tweeted highlight is
undoubtedly Namor who immediately
becomes one of the mcu's most
fascinating characters
if you scan the wakanda forever tweets
you'll notice one theme more than any
other the movie Perfectly honors
Chadwick Boseman there are hundreds upon
hundreds of tweets mentioning the late
actor and how the film pays its respects
to him one person said they became
emotional during their screening writing
I cried through the whole thing Chadwick
was honored so well he is missed
someone else agreed tweeting hashtag
wakanda forever is great very much
missed Chadwick as the character It's A
Beautiful film that honors his legacy
and expands the MCU like we said earlier
don't forget those tissues before
sitting down for wakanda forever many
tweets indicate the film is a tearjerker
with one reading what a beautiful and
emotional movie great performances from
the cast all around honors the legacy of
Chadwick Boseman in many meaningful ways
we have been kinda in a way we had been
keeping keeping him Alive by working on
the film and of course there were
criticisms you can't please everyone
these days especially movie fans while
it's difficult to find a tweet that
totally bashes wakanda forever there are
plenty that point out its flaws with one
viewer writing I was expecting so much
more the trailer looked amazing and the
movie at many times was meh I hated the
villain and I don't think his actions
were Justified when it comes to the not
so glowing comments about the movie it
looks like a lot of moviegoers thought
the 161 minute run time was just too
much someone else wrote it's a very
touching tribute that's done quite
Tastefully in most Parts but lots of the
other elements fall flat or get too
distracted also did not need to be quite
as long as it was another viewer agreed
adding beautiful tribute to Chadwick
Boseman but the film was too long looks
to be setting up much more if the
biggest complaint people have about
wakanda forever is that it's a little
bit too long we say it's still a winner
[Music]